this is from the post millennial Biden
calls up U.S military Reserve units to
deploy to active duty in Europe in
operation Atlantic resolve Atlantic
resolve is the official name of the
unofficial operation supporting the war
in Ukraine that is to say reserve
military actually let me just pull up
the executive order we have right here
from the uh from the white house.gov
selected reserve and the individual
ready reserve of the armed forces are
being called to active dirty active duty
to be deployed into Europe
the the official white house.gov
statement is by the authority vest enemy
as president et cetera et cetera and he
lists everything I hear about determine
is necessary to augment the active Armed
Force of the U.S for the effective
conduct of operation Atlantic resolve in
and around the United States European
commands area of responsibility now
I'm not a military guy I don't know
exactly what this means
but it certainly sounds like we are
inching closer to a major conflict
related to Russia potentially a World
War III scenario
I don't know what else to say other than
what do you guys think about it uh do
you guys have any knowledge experience
what do you guys think
yeah I'm I'm certainly frightened by the
news I'm probably not the person here
who has the most expertise on Military
and foreign policy but I think there's
real reason to be concerned let's pray
for this country and hope that we don't
get dragged into a third world war that
this doesn't escalate into something
that it doesn't need to be it's like I
believe that there is God that it's like
a real uh structure structure something
that's happening that's vibrating and
causing things to form like they're
happening like chimatics cymatics you
see where sound can cause matter to
change shape and that maybe we're here
to talk about this movie because this
war stuff is out of our hands we can
only
explain it yeah it's a it's a crazy time
yeah I'll tell you this I was in I've
been to Ukraine several times last year
um and so my my perspective is a little
different where I actually like what
Trump said about I want people to stop
dying like well let's de-escalate not
not escalate uh I spent time out there a
crazy story again my wife again uh
February 23rd I think it was last year
Russia invades Ukraine my wife comes up
to me in tears oh my gosh you got to go
to Ukraine and get those kids out like
what kids well we adopt children out of
Ukraine as part of one of the
foundations that she runs called
Children and Families we had seven kids
on the way out and she's like go get
them I'm like I'll call the teams like
no you have to go I'm a Catherine like
the bombs are dropping like she's like I
know she's crying and she's saying it
because she's very deliberate so when
she's irrational it's God I know that's
God when she's saying and I kid you not
create and he can verify this story
three hours later after Catherine's
telling me this I get a phone call from
Mel Gibson
and Mel Gibson says hey I got these kids
and and Ukraine these orphans who are I
think they're in the war zone can you go
get him out
and I'm like what like those signs right
there I've always been brought up with
the notion that if your wife and Mel
Gibson both tell you to do something you
know you probably better listen you
better listen anyway we went out there
worked with a group called aerial
recovery I'm on the board amazing group
6 000 women children got out so the
suffering that we saw and by the way I
won't get into this except we found a
pedophile group that was trafficking
children out of Ukraine into Mexico into
Ecuador crazy case Tony Robbins produced
the docuseries about it he's going to be
a producer as well but that's a
different story but my point is stop
de-escalating this thing the pain that
we're seeing the suffering that we're
seeing on the ground the part that no
one remembers traffickers call this
Harvest Time a war a hurricane an
earthquake in the aftermath Harvest Time
how is it a 150 billion dollar business
human trafficking how do you get that
many kids into that black market Harvest
Time Wars
hurricanes earthquake and it's happening
and no one that's the least reported
thing kids losing their parents kids
losing their parents this place this
place a nice van pulls up hey sweetie
get in the car we'll take care of you
next thing they wake up in in the
Caribbean like in Haiti I mean tell the
story when you went to uh save this
little kid what happened in the
orphanage I mean that's crazy man how
you know volunteers from all over the
world going to Haiti to you know find
children that they love their parents
because in one night thousands of
children
these traffickers just right they just
tried orphanage on the wall it's it's
his whether you think literally or
figuratively demonic oh yeah and it is
crazy to hear you're telling the story
here we are you know we're going to talk
about the film and your background we're
talking about the war and here you are
telling the story where your wife
Annabelle Gibson both call you and say
go save these kids you know part of me
is like I'm thinking there's a lot of
people who wish they would have some
kind of
the purpose being laid right before them
you have a job and I have to wonder
because I would imagine it's kind of
scary
but it's also a situation where you
can't say no exactly both both of those
you know people I'm just as scared as
anyone else going into Ukraine or going
into these these places I'll say this
though God is real and he loves children
because
every time once we're on the ground and
looking and there it goes away I don't
know I can't explain it it goes away and
I'm clear-minded I'm not I'm not worried
I'm not I'm not afraid to die in that
moment then afterwards I come I just
told you I can't watch out of freedom
it triggers me you know it's it I I'm
scared again after you know it's like
God will bless you in the moment you're
doing what he wants you to do but then
then you got to deal like you got to
deal with it before and after so what
made you decide in the beginning to get
involved rescuing kids
well I I I was my first job at the CIA I
was there through 911 and when I learned
about Muhammad Atta who was a terrorist
across over the Border uh Mexico into
the U.S and then and then launched his
attack I want to be on that border so I
I trained anti-trafficient
anti-terrorism stuff I have a graduate
degree in a certificate in hentai
terrorism so I got put on that border
that's where I wanted to be I speak
Spanish six months later they asked me
to be in the group child crimes I said
no so there's no way I'm going to go in
that group
um and my wife's agreed with me and then
the next morning before I said no she
she didn't sleep all night she was
crying and she said we have to say yes
oh my gosh if how can we be so fearful
of our own pain
uh that uh that we would disregard
severe pain beyond our comprehension of
these children so
Jesus I don't mean it's all about my
wife today
This Woman's dragging you to heaven man
and I'm going Kicking and Screaming
hopefully I'm going if
you know I don't know maybe maybe it's
inappropriate to say but uh if ever
there was someone with some kind of
Divine Purpose this the story that
you've told already I'm like man how
many people just wish they knew they had
that mission whether they whether they
were fearful of it or not like I said
it's probably scary but you tell these
stories and and so much of it sounds
unreal
the line from your wife the story from
the film story in a minute but
man it really does feel like you have a
purpose here that you are fulfilling I I
have to think I think so yeah I feel
that I feel that yeah I mean you're um
you're a humble man and you're saying
these things about the fact that you
were afraid and and your wife encouraged
you and surely she did but there are
many men whose wives would say save
those children who'd go we're not
talking about this honey absolutely not
yeah that's like I said I her script was
supposed to read get your ass home
because I got too many kids here what
would be like in the future what would
be your ideal outcome
for you
I whatever I'm gonna do I'm I I it'll be
attached always to this to this cause
because once you see it's like you can't
unring a bell right once you see it and
I'm hoping people are having this
experience with sound of Freedom now
because once you see it you cannot unsee
it and when the to the depths I've gone
it would be like I could never walk away
from from this work you know in some
capacity my undercover days are shot for
sure that's
you know thanks to this guy he he ruined
my undercover career but maybe maybe
we'll Inspire many more people that's
what we hope yeah that's what we have
tenfold that's 100 fold that's right not
to I mean outside of that uh we we talk
about uh the great work you've done the
film was masterfully done I thought it
was one of the best films I've seen in a
very very long time just in terms of the
production the the pacing the story
everything I think you guys nailed it
it's it's you know if you take a great
story and you do it wrong the story
doesn't make it you make a great film
you get out of the park now that story
that mission makes it somewhere I think
people often underestimate the
importance of filmmaking and making sure
people feel that emotion in that story
you know I think for me as a producer
the number one thing that you need to
have is the story the story is like the
is the soul of the movie without a good
story do you have nothing right so when
I met him mother eight years ago in Los
Angeles California I was with Alejandro
Monte Verde my business partner he's the
director of the film and he's the writer
of the film as well along with Rod bar
and when we met him and he told us what
he does around the world him and his
friends his you know his team they
travel around the world undercover
rescuing children that are kidnapped for
sex Transportation kids that are being
abused 10 to 15 times a day for many
years and then after that sometimes they
you know they don't want them anymore
because there's you know they're not you
know they're not fresh meat anymore
that's that's the vocabulary that they
use right so they go to uh this second
business which is Oregon's traffic they
open them and they sell their organs so
when you heard things like this man you
cannot look the other way around anymore
or you you have to do something and and
I remember like yesterday when Tim Balor
looked at me and he said Eduardo
Alejandro I know it's very sad what I'm
telling you I know that it's very sad
what I'm telling you about this children
the pain that they're going through but
it's more sad now that you know it if
you do nothing what are you gonna do and
and I knew at that time in Alejandro as
well that we we had to do something
we're filmmakers we have a weapon of
mass instruction and inspiration right
well let's make let's make a movie
because movies move people and media
influence how people think but let me
ask you a few questions first this is a
global problem right yes especially U.S
and Mexico us is the number one consumer
of child sex
Mexico number one provider
okay okay team
you live in the most powerful country in
the world you have the technology the
intelligence the money the the you know
the Army the police everything how come
we don't finish this problem in United
States and he said because it's not a
priority it's not a priority we are not
the solution I can be the solution for
one child for one thousand for three
thousands we're talking about millions
of children around the world that are
kidnapped for sex transportation we need
a movement
and that's when I realized hold on a sec
hold on a second you know a movie has
the potential to start a movement so
let's make a movie tell us what's the
most difficult Rescue Mission you've
ever done in your life the most
dangerous the most successful one he
said Cartagena Colombia the first one
tell me the story and he tells the story
and then we ask him what happened when
the kids were rescue oh man they were
crying with tears in their eyes they
were celebrating their freedom by by
singing it was like this sound of
Freedom that's the title and that's a
story then Alejandro right after he
started writing the script for three
years three years of uh Alejandro's life
and you know what happened to him right
before he started writing the script man
his father and his older brother
got kidnapped in Mexico wow and and they
killed him Alejandro Monte Verde wrote
Sound of Freedom with so much pain man
he put his soul his blood his suffering
in that movie and I know when people see
this movie sound of Freedom they feel
the pain of the kids they feel the
sacrifice of Tim Ballard they feel the
pain of the writer Alejandro Monte Verde
and we are honoring his father and his
son with this film too as well who are
in heaven along with my father who
passed away passed away last year thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time